we begin this morning with the death of
former President George Herbert Walker
Bush at the age of 94 for much of his
life mr. Bush was dedicated to serving
his country he was a world war ii
veteran a congressman from texas head of
the CIA and of course a vice president
he served only one term in the White
House after Bill Clinton defeated him in
the 92 election but his son George W
Bush our 43rd president was elected to
two terms they are only the second
father and son chief executives
following John Adams and John Quincy
Adams Norah O'Donnell has more on the
life of the 41st president it was 2011
when President Barack Obama awarded
George HW Bush the highest honor a
civilian can receive the Medal of
Freedom I'm a man who saves life in
terms of missions missions defined and
missions completed the son of a US
Senator he enlisted in the Navy on his
18th birthday becoming the Navy's
youngest fighter pilot during World War
two in 1944 his plane was shot down in
the Pacific I knew that if something
didn't pick me up I would be captured he
returned home a hero just weeks later he
married Barbara Pierce they had met at a
Christmas dance several years before I
think he says why is this smartest most
decent caring person I know after his
graduation from Yale in 1948 they moved
to Texas he built an oil business and
together they built a family they would
have six children but their first
daughter died of leukemia at age three
and a profound effect on me and on
Barbara and I think that horrible
incident drew us even closer together
in the early 60s mr. Bush pivoted to
politics he won two terms in the US
House then served presidents Nixon and
Ford as UN ambassador envoy to China and
director of the CIA in 1980
paying for the GOP presidential
nomination but instead became Ronald
Reagan's vice president eight years
later he won his party's nomination
I want a kinder and gentler nation he
waged a successful presidential campaign
against Democrat Michael Dukakis
faithfully execute the 41st president
called for a new world order as the
global scene shifted rapidly the Berlin
Wall fell then the Soviet Union in
Panama mr. Bush sent troops to overthrow
the corrupt regime of Manuel Noriega the
day of the dictator is over but a battle
with another dictator had only just
begun when Saddam Hussein's Iraqi forces
rolled into Kuwait President Bush
assembled a global coalition Operation
Desert Storm liberate Kuwait in six
weeks his popularity was sky-high after
the war but it plunged as he ran for
re-election the next year against Bill
Clinton an independent Ross Perot the
promise he made in his first campaign
came back to haunt him read my lips
he did raise taxes and emit an economic
slowdown he wound up losing in an
electoral landslide I couldn't do what
Ronald Reagan my friend and predecessor
did so well communicate effectively
enough with the river with the people
and that was my biggest shortcoming
President Bush's legacies include a
political dynasty his son George served
as governor of Texas and President of
the United States son Jeb was elected
governor of Florida and was a
presidential contender but perhaps his
life's greatest legacy is his marriage
to Barbara the bushes were together for
73 years longer than any other president
and first lady in US history our family
has had a front-row seat for the most
amazing love story at Barbara's funeral
Jeb Bush read a love letter his father
wrote his mother on their wedding
anniversary
in 1994 I have climbed the perhaps the
highest mountain in the world but even
that cannot hold a candle to being
Barbara's husband